la parole est à Monsieur remémy
pointerau pour le groupe UMP oui
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des Transports euh jeudi
dernier la commission mobilité 21
présidée par notre collègue député
Philippe Duron que vous aviez missionné
pour réviser le schéma national des
infrastructures de transport a rendu son
rapport et même si nous ne sommes pas
satisfaits des préconisations et des
délais de réalisation je veux saluer la
commission et son président pour leur
travail je me doute que vous allez nous
redire qu'il n'était pas possible de
financer les 70 projets du SNIT pour un
investissement de 245 milliards d'euros
sur 25 à 30 ans et que vos prédécesseurs
comme d'habitude avait commis une erreur
et un mensonge je veux rappeler je veux
rappeler je veux rappeler que l'ambition
du SNIT était d'aménager pour le long
terme notre pays en dotant
d'infrastructure routière faire
ferroviaire et fluvial des territoires
qui en avaient besoin pour permettre un
développement économique harmonieux
allant dans le sens de l'égalité des
territoires il n'y avait pas de promesse
d'ailleurs et sur les 70 projets ni
d'erreur ni de mensonges car un pays
comme le nôtre doit se projeter dans
l'avenir et donner des
perspectives une partie d'ailleurs de
ces projets étaai inscrit dans la loi du
Grenel de l'environnement et avait été
voté à la quasi unanimité au
Sénat a le mérite de hiérarchiser et de
prioriser les projets mais il déçoit par
son manque d'ambition et d'audace autant
dans la majorité que dans l'opposition
on est loin de réenchanter le rêve
français promis par le candidat Hollande
à la
présidentielle monsieur le ministre bien
sûr les finances publiques sont au plus
bas bien sûr il n'échappe à personne que
cela vous oblige à faire des arbitrages
mais de grâce faitesles sur le le
fonctionnement de l'État et pas sur les
investissements car nous sommes dans le
renoncement avec seulement 8 à 10
milliards d'euros de travaux d'ici 2030
pour financer un nombre réduit de
projets alors même que la relance de la
croissance passe forcément par des
Investissements d'Avenir capable de
produire de la richesse immédiatement et
surtout durablement grâce à des
financements innovants et pourquoi pas
un grand emprunt d'État car il y a la
bonne et la mauvaise dette la mauvaise
dette c'est celle qui consiste à
rembourser du fonctionnement par emprunt
et la bonne dette celle qui est investie
dans un outil productif comme une pour
une entreprise un pays qui n'investit
plus c'est un pays qui s'appauvrit et
qui se meurt monsieur le ministre quel
est le devenir de ce rapport pour
certains projets LGV comme
l'interconnexion sud ou le pocle le
débat public a déjà eu lieu les études
sont en cours les populations attendent
allez-vous poursuivre les études votre
gouvernement est-il prêt à mettre des
moyens supplémentaires pour un plan de
relance des infrastructures merci votre
ATT
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur remémi poinre merci
de faire à la fois les questions et les
réponses puisque vous-même avez pu
souligner le caractère irréaliste et
irréalisable du schéma national des
infrastructures de transport tel qu'il
est présenté et d'ailleurs cette
critique n'est pas celle d'un seul côté
de cette hémicycle puisqu'il fut cette
critique est particulièrement partagée y
compris de certains de mes prédécesseurs
parce que le schéma national des
infrastructures de de de transport est
en effet une liste non hiérarchisée non
financée de 70 dossiers projets dont
certains n'ont pas de réalité puisque un
certain nombre d'études sont en cours y
compris sur la faisabilité même de ce
ces projets c'est dire que euh nous
avons euh face à à nous des territoires
qui ont cru pouvoir obtenir des
infrastructures teles que celle-là leur
avait été annoncé plus grave un certain
nombre de projets ont été lancés souvent
des des projets qui eux-mêmes coûtent
plusieurs milliards en même temps 4 LGV
de sorte que vous avez passé la commande
nous payons l'addition et que
aujourd'hui le loyer que la fite aura à
payer pour 20 ans c'est un loyer de 200
millions simplement sur les quatre
schémas auxquels et quatre lignes dont
je viens de parler mais j'aurais
souhaité puisque vous avez été l'auteur
le co-auteur avec le président Jacques
min d'un excellent rapport concernant le
lien entre les collectivités
territoriales les infur infrastructure
de transport bien évidemment j'avais
participé et qui a été présenté devant
votre assemblée de pouvoir mettre le
lien sur ce qui est attendu en fait un
projet et les grands projets
d'infrastructure entre le temps du débat
public et la réalisation c'est 20 ans or
précisément l'engagement du président de
la République et l'attente des
populations et des élus c'est de pouvoir
répondre aussi surtout avec une cohésion
dans l'investissement public dans la
contractualisation publique de pouvoir
répondre aux enjeux des territoire au
quotidien de pouvoir apporter solution à
la dégradation continue tant du système
ferroviaire que du système routier ou
autoroutier et de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une priorisation des enjeux vous me
demandez ce que nous ferons du SNIT dès
le 9 juillet donc dans quelques jours le
le Premier ministre annoncera un grand
plan d'investissement public dont un des
volets concernera les transports et qu'à
partir de cette date une dialogue une
coconstruction avec les régions sera
engagé pour que nous puissions fixer les
orientations les priorités la
réalisation mais mesdames mieurs vous ne
manquerez pas de venir me voir au
ministère je suis persuadé et là
peut-être puisque j'ai bien entendu
qu'il ne s'agissait pas de promesse
qu'il y avait dans le
S peut-être plus raisonnable sur la
soutenabilité des investissements
publics là où des déficits étaient
plutôt le le propre de votre politique
merci